what line what is line the guy's a lot
of you are enjoying things that are
dropping at comic-con I want to do a
video for you on a trailer I genuinely
enjoyed before we get full sweaty on
comic-con [ __ ] talking about the trailer
for the disaster artist I want to do a
video on it because I genuinely liked
this trailer one of the most
entertaining trailers I've seen yet I
think I've seen this more than the
Ultron trailer when that drop and the
disaster artist is ultimately a movie
about the making of the masterpiece
called the room blotter opposed to
review that one I might before this
movie comes out to give it context
Ezreal is very simple in its execution
just the famous scene from the room
where he's on the roof and he simply has
to say I did not hit her it's not true
it's [ __ ] I did not hit her I did
not oh hi mark I did not hit her it's
not true it's [ __ ] I did not hit her
I did not oh hi mark
the days I've got to do 67 takes later
and this movie is based on the book
written by the guy who plays mark in the
room you know Gabe Franco played him in
the movie and I heard the book is damn
entertaining and what went on behind the
scenes of this I can only imagine and
there's really a take after take after
take of James Franco laying the made
dude from the room who also wrote the
room just [ __ ] it up the first line
is I did not hit her at one point
because there's like I hit her Seth
Rogen's like now would you want to
change the lines like we're open to that
if that will get us through this
disaster I find it hysterical that a
movie has been made like James Franco
Seth Rogen dave Franco some comedic
powerhouse behind this telling a story
about what happened behind the scenes
because this movie became such an
infamous phenomenon
probably just so much to know and after
about 67 sakes and that's minimum so
they just show you in the trailer the
crew knows the line is like right what
is line and they all in unison to like I
did not hit her it's not true it's
[ __ ] I did not hit her I did not oh
hi mark he finally landed and the dude
looks super positive given hug and he
gives you context to know that's like
that's why the shittiest take imaginable
was accepted as that's good enough I did
not hit her it's not true it's [ __ ]
I did not hit her I did not oh hi mark
just [ __ ] that if they're doing that
[ __ ] again greatest thing is when you
realize that dude
actually also wrote the room yeah the
dude who's trying to execute the lines
in the room who doesn't know the lines
in the room wrote the room
I've holy [ __ ] I love the fact that
every other take he does not have the
water bottle and it take that works he
has the water bottle in his hands that
he throws sometimes like I did not oh hi
mark
doctor's room they gave him a water
bottle because he's been in that little
shed Shack thing for 6070 eggs there's
probably a hot he's probably dehydrated
he absent mindedly walked out with it I
just wanted to share this with you
because you know the rooms an infamous
movie I've only heard its infamous
admittedly I've never seen it I've
always been like why the [ __ ] would I
put myself through that
I was watching scenes from the room
after I watch this trailer I was like
okay I feel like it's spoiling movie now
did its spoiler territory I officially
probably should watch this movie I don't
know how much alcohol I'm gonna need
don't know how much anything I'm gonna
need if you guys haven't seen the room I
completely understand neither have I but
I've heard the tale I've heard the
stories and this trailer just makes it
more interesting I'll put a link below
to the scene from the room that this
trailer is showing the behind the scenes
of don't put a link to the trailer below
watch the scene from the room firstly
have context if you've never seen it
before and watch the trailer any other
cracked me up in the trailer for what it
was trying to do which is simply perfect
alright guys so the disaster artist
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it or have you seen the room
what did you think about that whatever
you thank comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here cuz they mo are
you
[Music]